اسرائيليه ادى منفذ عمليه الدهس قتل
برصاصي شخص مسلح صادف مروره بالمكان
بعد الان من بيت صفافه جنوبيه القدس
مراسله
كرام ليطلعن على طبيعه ما يجري والروايات
في هذا الاطار الياس
نعم نحن نتواجد الان في بيت صفافه جنوب
القدس المحتله تحديدا عند منزل منفذ عمليه
الدهس وفق الشرطه الاسرائيليه وكانت
الشرطه سويه قد غادرت قبل قليل هذا الموقع
بعد ان داهمت منزل منفذ العمليه بقوات
معززه من شرطه حرس الحدود ورجال المخابرات
الذين اقتحموا منزل العائله
واعتقلوا والد منفذ العمليه واشقاء اشقائه
وايضا زوجته واقتادوهم للتحقيق كما يبدو
انهم صادروا مواد او ربما اغراض تخص منفذ
العمليه لمعرفه ربما او الوقوف على حقيقه
ما حصل نشير هنا الى ان روايه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تشير الى ان الشهيد حاتم نجمي
هو منفذ هذه العمليه في سوق محاني يهودا
في القدس الغربيه عصر هذا اليوم وهي تقول
بانه قام بعمليه
في ذروه التسوق في سوق يهدى الروايه
الاسرائيليه تشير الى ان خمسه اسرائيليين
اصيبوا في عمليه الدهس هذه اصابه احدهم
وصفت بانها في غايه الخطوره وهذه العمليه
تاتي في ذروه استنفار امني من جانب قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ومن جانب الشرطه
الاسرائيليه في معظم المدن الاسرائيليه
لاسيما عشيه احتفالات اسرائيل بيوم
تاسيسها او بعام تاسيسها الخامس
والسبعين الذي يصادف يوم الاربعاء المقبل
وبالتالي هنالك تعزيزات امنيه سواء كان
ذلك في القدس او في مدن اسرائيليه اخرى في
داخل اسرائيل تحسبا من عمليات من هذا
القبيل الشرطه الاسرائيليه ما زالت تحقق
في ظروف ما حصل عصر هذا اليوم في سوق محني
يهود هذا السوق الشعبي المقتض
بالاسرائيليين
عاده في هذه الساعه التي نفذت فيها
العمليه نشيرنا الى ان عابر سبيل اسرائيلي
مسلح بمسدسه كان اطلق عده مصاصات بشكل
مباشر ولمسافه قريبه جدا على الشهيد نجمه
وارده شهيد شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرم